[موسيقى]
تركيا امام مرحله جديده من تاريخها انتهت
معركه الانتخابيه وصفت بانها الاصعب منذ
وصول حزب العداله والتنميه الى الحكم في
تركيا عام 2002 بفوز رجب طيب اردوغان في
ولايه رئاسيه جديده لكن خلال هذه المعركه
اثير تساؤلات تبقى تبحث عن اجابات سياسيه
لامراض الاقتصاد وتخفيف معاناه المواطنين
من اثار التضخم وارتفاع الاسعار وازاله
اثار الزلزال الذي ضرب مناطق واسعه من
البلاد وعن كيفيه التعامل مع اللاجئين
السوريين في ظل موجه عداء شارك فيها ساسه
ومرشحون وفي راي مراقبين كان تنافس على
الرئاسه تنافسا بين رؤيتين لدور تركيا
ومستقبلها رؤيه تبناها المرشح المنهزم
كمال اوغلو وتلقى صداها لدى قطاعات في
الشارع التركي تستند الى العلمانيه التي
ارساها مصطفى كمال اتاتورك وجعلها تيمم
وجهها شطر الغرب رؤيه يمثلها الرئيس
الفائز رجب طيب اردوغان وقطاعات اخرى في
الشارع التركي وتؤمن بمد خطوط الوصل
التاريخيه مع العربي والعالم الاسلامي دون
التخلي عن العلاقات مع الغرب انتهت اذا
المعركه الانتخابيه غير ان الاستقطاب بين
الرؤيتين جزء من الحياه السياسيه في قصتنا
الليله التقارب التركي العربي نرصد بعضا
من جوانبه من زاويه علاقات تركيا مع
العالم العربي التي شهدت دفعه قويه منذ
تولي حزب العداله والتنميه الحكم شابه
توتر وخلافات خلال ثورات الربيع العربي
الا ان انقر عاده مؤخرا الى سياسه تصفير
وتصفيه مشاكلها وخلافاتها مع عديد الدول
العربيه نتناول ابعاد وتطور العلاقات
التركيه مع العالم العربي مع رجال اعمال
ودبلوماسيين وساسه يمثلون مختلف المشاربي
في تركيا ونركز على الفرص التي يمثلها
التعاون الاقتصادي والامني للجانبين وهل
يمكن ان يمتد لشراكه استراتيجيه تجد لها
موطئ قدم في نظام عالمي جديد تتشكل ملامحه
نستكمل بقيه هذه القصه مع ضيفينا الكريمين
رسول النائبه السابق في حزب العداله
والتنميه والدكتور حسين باكير الاستاذ في
مركز ابن خلدون بجامعه قطر نسالهما عن
الثوابت والمتغيرات في السياسه الخارجيه
التركيه تجاه الدول العربيه وهواجيس دول
عربيه من التدخلات التركيه في العراق
وسوريا وليبيا وعن مدى قدره الجانبين على
تطوير علاقاتهما والحفاظ على مصالحهم
المشتركه وتجنيبها تاثير الخلافات
السياسيه العابره لكن ما رايكم بدايه ان
نشاهد القصه وبعدها نبدا الحوار
[موسيقى]
في العام
1923 وخلال مفاوضات لوزان نشرت مجله
التايم عنوانا يقول تركيا تولي وجهها غربا
كان وجه الجمهوريه الجديده يتجه غربا
بالفعل ليس في الثقافه فقط بل في السياسه
الخارجيه كذلك
ارقص نقل صوت منذ بدايه الحرب البارده
وتركيا عضو وحليف قوي في حلف الناتو وهذا
ادى الى انغلاق تركيا عن العالم كما شهدت
العلاقات بين تركيا والشرق الاوسط قطيعه
على مستويات الدول وقطيعه ثقافيه
من الازمه القبرصيه في عام 63
اعاد الشرق الاوسط الى معادله السياسه
التركيه من جديد
حين توجهت تركيا للامم المتحده لاتخاذ
قرار بهذا الشان مع الاسف تركت وحيده ولم
يدعمها احد لذلك قررت انها بحاجه الى
اتخاذ وضع جديد من اجل مصلحته القوميه
الاعظم اما الخطوه الاوسع فجاءت منتصف
التسعينيات مع محاوله رئيس الوزراء التركي
نجم الدين اربكان تاسيس مجموعه اقتصاديه
اسلاميه تكون مصر احد اعضائها لتكون حاضره
في اول اجتماع للمجموعه يعقد في اسطنبول
عام 97 رامز ساهم دخول الرئيس الوزراء
الراحل بركان معتركه السياسه التركيه في
تنميه التجاره مع دول العربيه في ذلك
الحين لم يكن تطوير التجاره مع الدول
العربيه على جدول اعمال تركيا او بان
الوجهه كانت دائما هي تطوير التجاره مع
اوروبا وامريكا
[موسيقى]
الا ان نقطه التحول الاساسي لتركيا في
سياستها الخارجيه كانت عام 2003 مع رفض
البرلمان التركي السماح للقوات الامريكيه
الدخول الى شمال العراق عبر اراضيه عشيه
الغزو الامريكي بالتزامن مع صعود حزب
العداله والتنميه واعتماده مفهوم العمق
الاستراتيجي في سياسته الخارجيه حيث
الاتصال بالعمق الجغرافي جنوبا ودائرته
العربيه بما يربطه به تاريخيا وثقافيا
فتره حزبنا حزب العداله والتنميه وقد شهدت
مزيدا من التقدم في علاقاتنا مع العلم
العربي والاسلامي مقارنه بالفترات السابقه
والسبب في ذلك ان مهمه حزبنا مرتبطه
بالرساله والمبادئ التي يحددها بنفسه من
خلال تركيا
ان وصول حزب العداله والتنميه للحكم قد
عزز العلاقات بشكل ايجابي وكونهم شخصيات
تولي اهميه للعلاقات مع الدول الاسلاميه
ادى الى توثيق العلاقات التركيه مع الشرق
الاوسط والدول الاسلاميه
هناك نوع من التحول في السياسه الخارجيه
التركيه بعد وصول حزب العداله والتنميه
الى السلطه تغيير حزب العداله والتنميه
سلوك السياسه الخارجيه لتركيا السياسه
الخارجيه التقليديه بمعنى ان تركيا كانت
دائما تنتهج نوعا من السياسه الخارجيه
المحايده وهي المبادئ التي تم اتباعها
خلال الفتره الجمهوريه وهذا هو الذي
اخذناه من مصطفى كمال اتاتورك
رغم الاصوات الداخليه المعارضه للسياسه
الخارجيه الجديده الا انه تم توقيع
اتفاقيه مجلس التعاون الاستراتيجي مع كل
من سوريا والعراق في 2009 واتفاق المناطق
الحره بين تركيا وسوريا ولبنان والاردن
عام 2010
بالكلام تركي الى رب الكريم تتمتع تركيا
والدول العربيه بعلاقه وثيقه للغايه في
عده نواحي نحن نتقاسم نفس الجغرافيا فهم
جيراننا ولدينا تاريخ مشترك نحن لا نتحدث
عن بضعه قرون بل نتحدث عن تاريخ مشترك
لاكثر من الف سنه معا في هذه الجغرافيا
لم تاهو تركيا دوله احاديه
بل بدا بتنفيذ سياسه خارجيه دبلوماسيه
متعدده الاطراف والاتجاهات وذلك لموقعها
جيوسياسي مما يجعل حوارها اقوى مع الدول
العربيه كما اننا لا نستطيع ان نكون
بعيدين او منعزلين عن الشرق الاوسط
[موسيقى]
قصدي
حريصه القياده الجديده على تاكيد رؤيه
مختلفه بسياسه تركيا الخارجيه وزياده حضور
الدور التركي في القضايا المحوريه في
المنطقه كالقضيه الفلسطينيه ما اكسبها
شعبيه متزايده في الاوساط العربيه الشعبيه
ومكثفه منذ فتره طويله جدا اهمها قضيه
فلسطين والقدس ان القضيه الفلسطينيه جرح
ينزف في المنطقه منذ اكثر من 50 عاما هذه
واحده من اهم البنود الموجوده على الاجنده
اليوميه في جميع اللقاءات والاجتماعات بين
تركيا والدول العربيه
يشكل المنظور التالي دوما النظره المركزيه
لنظره تركيا للمنطقه والشعب الفلسطيني
والم الاخرى لكن بما ان القضيه الفلسطينيه
هي قضيتنا المشتركه فيمكننا القول ان
العلاقات التي اقناها ومركزها القضيه
الفلسطينيه والمقدسيه تساهم ايضا في تكوين
وتطوير علاقات جاده بين بلدنا ودولنا في
العالم العربي
[موسيقى]
ساعه تركيا لبناء علاقات مع دول العالم
العربي تقوم على المصالح المتبادله
والقضايا المشتركه الا انها وجدت نفسها
امام مفترق طرق فرضته خياراتها السياسيه
[موسيقى]
رحب تركيا بالربيع العربي بشكل ايجابي
للغايه لان تركيا دوله تحكمها الديمقراطيه
والربيع العربي يمثل رغبه الشعب العربي
والشارع العربي في الديمقراطيه والحياه
الكريمه
هل يمكن ان يحدث هذا لنا خصوصا الدول التي
لا تسمح لها بنيتها الاجتماعيه السياسيه
بما حدث في الربيع العربي لذلك اتخذت
موقفا سلبيا تجاه تركيا لكن بعد وقت ليس
بالبعيد قاموا بتقييم وضعهم يعني هو
النهارده
امرا معيبا جدا
وينبغي العمل على وقفها باي شكل من
الاشكال واظن ان هناك يعني رفض ومقاومه
عربيه
جادتين
لهذا النوع من
التدخلات سياسه الخارجيه لحزب العداله
والتنميه قد غيرت السياسه التقليديه
للجمهوريه التركيه والتدخل في الشؤون
الداخليه للدول العربيه وجيراننا ليس
بالشيء الذي نقدره او نسعى اليه كما ان
ذلك لم يحظى بقبول الدول العربيه والشعوب
العربيه نفسها
تتاثر العلاقات بين تركيا والدول العربيه
بالسياسه الى حد كبير لكن مع اوروبا
فالامر مختلف على سبيل المثال حين تتوتر
العلاقه بين تركيا واوروبا بسبب العديد من
القضايا التجاره تزداد بشكل مستمر
والسياسه تعمل بشكل منفصل عن التج اره لكن
الدول العربيه ليست كذلك
شكل الاقتصاد احد اهم دوافع التوجه
التركيه نحو العرب حيث احتل العراق المركز
الاول في الدول المستورده من تركيا والذي
يعتبر رابع اكبر مستورد في العالم
للمنتجات التركيه بحجم تبادل تجاري يتجاوز
العشرين مليار دولار كما بلغ التبادل
التجاري مع دول الخليج ثمانيه مليار دولار
مع الامارات واربعه واثنين من عشره مليار
دولار مع السعوديه وواحد وسته من عشره
مليار دولار مع قطر
شمال افريقيا والشرق الاوسط والخليج منطقه
ضخمه وواسعه لذا فهي وجهه جيده جدا
بالنسبه لنا للاستيراد والتصدير الدولي
ويمكننا دعم بعضنا البعض في تحسين
علاقاتنا الاقتصاديه
هي احد الاسباب المهمه لتطوير الاقتصاد
التركي والتكنولوجيا تتطلب علاقات مكثفه
مع دول المتقدمه والصناعيه التي توجد بشكل
رئيسي في الغرب لذلك اعتقد ان التوجه
الغربي لتركيا نتيجه لهذه الاسباب
علاقتنا تجاريه في المغرب تتطور بشكل سريع
للغايه علاقتنا مع مصر جيده جدا ولا تزال
العلاقات التجاريه والتصدير مع مصر مستمرا
كما يواصل المستثمرون الاتراك استثمارات
ايموناك في تركيا لديها سياسه افريقيه
ملموسه للغايه فهي تعتبر شمال افريقيا
بوابه مهمه جدا لتركيا
[موسيقى]
منطقه المغرب العربي البوابه الى افريقيا
حيث ناهزت قيمه التبادلات التجاريه
التركيه مع القاره الافريقيه 25 مليار
دولار في العام 2020
هناك واجهه كبيره على البحر المتوسط هناك
دول افريقيه مجاوره كثيره جدا هناك عمق
افريقي
مباشره الى وسط افريقيا او بالتالي الموقع
الجغرافي الليبي مهم جدا لاي دوله تريد ان
تصنع علاقات وطيده داخل القاره الامريكيه
ومنها تركيا
الاستثمار المتبادل بين تركيا والدول
الشقيقه او دول الخليج او الدول التي
تمتلك راس المال في شمال افريقيا سيقوي
الاقتصاد التركي وينمي صادرات ويساعد كذلك
في الحد من مشكله البطاله في تركيا تركيا
[موسيقى]
بقوه اقتصاديه جيده في عده مجالات مثل
قطاع السياحه والصناعه والمنتجات الزراعيه
ويمكننا انتاج منتجات ذات نوعيه جيده كذلك
نحتاج الى تحسين موارد الطاقه لدينا
والتمتع باستقلاليه في انتاج الطاقه لذلك
من الجيد ان تكون لديك علاقات جيده مع
جميع الدول العربيه
[موسيقى]
تعاظمت الاهميه الجيو اقتصاديه لمنطقه شرق
البحر المتوسط مع اكتشافات المخزونات
الضخمه من النفط والغاز الطبيعي حيث تبلغ
الاحتياطات نحو واحد وسبعه من عشره مليار
برميل لنفط
و122 تريليون قدم مكعب من الغاز حيث تهدف
تركيا الى تعزيز اندماجها في بنيه امن
الطاقه الاقليميه بما تمتلكه من حقوق
بحريه تمكنها من استحقاق نصيبها من الغاز
المستخرج لتكون محورا اساسيا محتملا
للامدادات المتجهه الى اوروبا من خلال
اتفاقيات وتفاهمات مع اطراف دوليه من
بينها عربيه في اقليم حوض المتوسط
توقيع على مذكره التفاهم بال 27 نوفمبر
عام 2019
اصبح من اولويات الحكومه التركيه
هو المحافظه على هذه المذكره
واستغلال واستثمار
الثروه الموجوده في الاراضي التي حكمتها
هذه
المذكره تركيا قد تجد في هذا الملف
يعني يقول ان جاء الكبرى الاقتصاديه
للدوله الذ
[موسيقى]
ترى انقره ان الازمات التي شهدتها دول
المنطقه قد فرضت عليها ادوارا امنيه
وعسكريه لتامين حدودها الجغرافيه من جهه
وتامين مصالحها الجيوستراتيجيه من جهه
اخرى وتنتشر قواتها وقواعدها العسكريه
لتحقيق ذلك متجاوزه محيطها الجغرافي وصولا
للصومال
تشكل استقرار الدول العربيه استقرار سوريا
استقرار العراق استقرار منطقه الشرق
الاوسط استقرار ليبيا
لشكلنه يعود على تركيا
بفوائد اكبر من الفوائد الموجوده
الان وتدخل تركيا العسكري في 2019 ينصب
وينطلق من هذا الباب ومن هذا المنطلق بعد
اهتمام تركيا باستقرار المنطقه واضحا في
استجابتها السريعه لقطر مع بدايه الازمه
الخليجيه عبر مد خطوط التجاره بجسر جوي
وبحري للتعويض نقص البضائع او تاسيس قاعده
الريان العسكريه عام 2014 في اعقاب ازمه
سحب سفراء الدولي مجلس التعاون
[موسيقى]
اكبر تهديد للمنطقه هو عدم الاستقرار فاذا
طلبت دوله صديقه من تركيا امرا يتعلق
بالامن العسكري بناء على المصالح المشتركه
والاهتمامات والقضايا التي تجمعنا بها فان
تركيا جاهزه للمساعده فان تركيا شريك
موثوق به للغايه في صناعه الامن والدفاع
العسكري وبعباره اخرى تركيا وجيشها شريك
موثوق به للغايه في هذا الاتجاه
الاقتصاد لا يمكن ان يعمل منفردا لذا يجب
ان تتبع العلاقات الاقتصاديه علاقات
عسكريه في نفس الوقت لاجراء مفاوضات جيده
بحسب احصاءات السبري تتصدر دول عربيه
كالسعوديه والامارات وقطر وعمان قائمه
مستوردي الاسلحه التركيه التي بلغ اجمالي
صادراتها عام 2021 مليارين
و794 مليون دولار
نحن لدينا صناعه دفاعيه متطوره وشركات
دوليه مؤهله للغايه فنحن ننتج بعض
المنتجات الدفاعيه المرضيه للغايه مثل
المسيرات وبعض التقنيات المحسنه
اعتقد ان الامر ربما لا يتعلق بتركيا فقط
لانها تنتج الاسلحه وتبيعها لهذه الدول
ربما في الفتره القادمه يمكن تطوير مشاريع
مشتركه بعباره اخرى فان لدى تركيا تراكم
التكنولوجيا حينما يتحد مع راس المال
العربي قد تخرج منتجات جديده
[موسيقى]
توجه تركي لخلق مساحات من المصالح
المشتركه مع العمق العربي وفتح الصفحه
جديده في العلاقات رغم تعقيدات المشهد
الاقليمي فهل تشهد الايام القادمه تحالفا
استراتيجيا جديدا في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
هناك فرق بين السياسه الخارجيه التقليديه
العامه والسياسه الخارجيه التي يمارسها
حزب العداله والتنميه اذا قمنا بهذا
التمييز فيمكننا فهم ما يحدث حقا لان
الارث الذي تلقيناه من اتاتورك هو التوجه
نحو الغرس
لقد بنينا
هذا بالاضافه الى ذلك فان ايماننا
وثقافتنا هما من الروابط التي تربطنا
ببعضنا البعض يجب ان نحدد نموذجا واطارا
لعلاقتنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام نرحب بكم
وبضيفينا الكريمين من اسطنبول رسول طوسون
النائب السابق عن حزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكم في تركيا وهنا في الاستوديو
الدكتور علي حسين بكير استاذ في مركز ابن
خلدون بجامعه قطر لعنا نبدا من مكان الحدث
مع السيد رسول طوسون ونتساءل حقيقه سيد
الرسول يعني انتهت هذه الانتخابات
الرئاسيه بتجديد الثقه بالرئيس اردوغان
لكنها اظهرت تباينا او وجهتين
التباين فيما يخص التوجه التركي
كسياسه خارجيه وجهه النظر الاولى تحدثنا
عن ذلك في التقرير عن التاكيد على التوجه
نحو العالم العربي لكن هناك وجهه نظر
ثانيه تجد صداها في الشارع التركي متعلقه
بالتوجه نحو الغرب السؤال حقيقه الليله
كيف ستؤثر وجهه النظر الثانيه في الصوغ
ملامح السياسه الخارجيه
في العهده الجديده للرئيس اردوغان
السياسه الخارجيه
يتبناها الرئيس حكومات الرئيس اردوغان
وبالضبط الرئيس اردوغان هو الذي
يخطط اهداف
السياسه الخارجيه عندما استلم الرئيس
اردوغان
السده الحكم سنه 2002
فاعلنا انه سيفتح صفحه بيضاء جديده في
السياسه الخارجيه
واعلن ان العلاقات ستكون مع الجيران فكما
سموها
بتصفير المشاكل
وتركيا ايضا اعلنت بانه لم تكن تتجه الى
الغرب فقط انما تركيا
تشكل
قنطره او جسرا بين الغرب بالشرق تركيا
دوله اسيويه
واوروبيه لا تدير ظهرها الى الشرق ولا الى
الغرب فتركيه كما هي كانت دوله اوروبيه في
العهد العثماني
امتد الى اواسط الاوروبيه اواسط اوروبا
الى
ابوابنا فلذلك سياسه الرئيس اردوغان ليست
منحصره
بالتوجه الى الغرب
بتجيد بتحصين العلاقات مع الغرب ايضا
تحصين العلاقات مع الشرق مع العالم
الاسلامي وايضا مع عالم الثالث حيث اعلن
الرئيس اردوغان سنه 2005 عام عام سنه
افريقيا فان فتحت تركيا الى افريقيا كانت
هناك فقط 12 سفاره والان وصلت يعني
مراكز الدبلوماسيه في افريقيا الى 44
فكمان مر في التقرير يعني السياسه
الخارجيه التركيه في عهد اردوغان ليست
منحصره او محكومه لاوروبا ولا الى روسيا
العديد الاطراف وضح ذلك سيد الرسول دعني
اتحول الى ضيف الكريم هنا دكتور علي حقيقه
نتساءل معك الدكتور علي شكل العلاقه
باعتقادك بالنظر للسجلات وتبين وجهات
النظر التي رايناها خلال هذه الحمله
الانتخابيه فيما يخص العالم العربي وهل
العالم العربي يمكن وصفه بعالم عربي واحد
سنفصل ونتحدث عن عده اجزاء من العالم
العربي وطريقه التعامل التركيه ايضا معها
العالم العربي تحول خلال المرحله الاخيره
الى ماده سجليه كبيره في الداخل التركي
وهذه الانتخابات طبعا سلطه الضوء على هذا
السجال الذي كان في جزء منه طبعا هو صراع
هويات ايضا في الداخل التركي انعكس بشكل
من الاشكال على الموضوع العالم العربي
هناك في تركيا من يريد ان يعزل تركيا عن
محيطها الجغرافي المتعلق بالشرق الاوسط
والعالم العربي وان يعزلها ايضا عن
تاريخها وعن هويتها وان يضعها كذيل لدى
الغرب بحيث تكون تابعه لهذا المعسكر الذي
يسمونه بالعالم المتحضر طبعا رؤيه حزب
العداله والتنميه والفريق الاخر مختلفه
تماما هي ترى ان تركيا جزء من تاريخ
وجغرافيه المنطقه وهذه الجغرافيه ليست
طارئه او مستجده والتاريخ ليس طارئه مسج
وانما يمتد الى الف عام وفي مرحله من
المراحل كانت تركيا قائده لهذا الاقليم
اكثر من 400 سنه وبالتالي من غير المنطقي
عزل تركي عن هذا الاطار ولذلك معظم كان
هذه السياسات كانت تتجه باتجاه الانفتاح
العالم العربي طبعا العالم العربي ليس
كتله صماء هناك اختلافات في النظم السي
وهناك اختلافات ايضا بين النظم
مثلا سوريا ومصر راينا يعني عوده على
الاقل محاوله لعوده العلاقات التركيه مع
هذين البلدين هل ستمضي باعتقادك في
المرحله القادمه ربما نحن مصالحه شامله مع
القاهره وتقارب ربما اكثر مع النظام
السوري وفق ايه وتيره ما الذي سيحكم ربما
هذه العلاقه وشكلها طبعا هو هذه التقارب
والعمليات التطبيع الجاريه جزء من مرحله
خفض التصعيد في المنطقه بدات بعد هزيمه
الرئيس ترامب ومجيء بايدن وايضا بعد جائحه
كوفي 19 والمصالحه ايضا الخليجيه التي
بدات مع السعوديه وقطر طبعا ضمن هذه
الاطار الجانب تركي كان له دور ايضا في
هذه المصالحات وهناك عمليات تطبيع جاريه
اعتقد ان هذه العمليه ستستمر الان بزخم
اكبر مع
في مرحله ما بعد الانتخابات لكن حاله مصر
تختلف كليا عن حاله سوريا اعتقد ان
العلاقه مع مصر ستشهد تطورا كبيرا في
المرحله القادمه سيكون التركيز على ثلاثه
قضايا الرئيسيه الاستثمار والتجاره بشكل
اساسي شرق حوض البحر المتوسط والملف
بالفعل هناك تباين بين الطرفين كون هناك
تقريبا عوده للسفارات وفتح للسفارات بين
الطرفين بلدان شمال افريقيا التي تشكل
ايضا يعني
المستعمرات الغربيه القديمه والتي يعز على
الغرب عليها كان كما ذكرت ضيفنا الكريم من
اسطنبول
محاولات للتقارب وراينا ايضا علاقات قويه
تنسج مع هذه الدول هل سنرى ربما
ذها اكثر وضغطا اكثر على الغرب في هذه
النقطه من قبل تركيا بالتاكيد الغير منزعج
جدا من الدوري التركي هناك لا سيما في
الجزائر وايضا في المغرب ايضا الجانب
التركي واعي للحسيساسيات الموجوده بين دول
شمال افريقيا العربيه وهو يتعامل مع كل
دوله بما يقتضيه الامر مع الجزائر على
سبيل المثال هناك تركيز عالي على التبادل
التجاري والاستثمار والطاقه واليوم تركيا
هي اكبر مستثمر في الجزائر والجزائر لديها
ايضا استثمارات في تركيا على مستوى الطاقه
والغاز مع المغرب على سبيل المثال هناك
تعاون متزايد من ناحيه الصناعات الدفاعيه
هناك تصدير لاسلحه متقدمه من بينها درونز
حصل خلال المرحله الماضيه اعتقد ان
التركيز سيستمر
دول الخليج والتركيز الاساسي هو على
الاقتصاد والاستثمار والان هو الدور
الحقيقه اكثر اهميه لهذه الدول في تحقيق
تكامل اقتصادي مع تركيا حيث المال
والاستثمار من الدول الخليجيه والخبره
والتكنولوجيا
والعمل البشري من الجانب التركي السيد
رسول عوده الان الى يكون يحاول ان نفصل
حقيقه بعد ان وضعنا الامور في نصابها صح
التعبير فيما يخص العلاقات التركيه
العربيه اي نوع لهذه العلاقات تريده تركيا
هل هو اقتصادي وفقط ام انها تمتد ربما
لمستوى شركات استراتيجيه ما شكلها كيف
سيكون من وجهه النظر التركيه هذه العلاقه
يعني مع الدول العربيه باختلافها
اولا يجب ان نشير الى الرؤيه التي يتمتع
به الرئيس اردوغان وهو ان المفروض ان
الشعوب العربيه او الامه الاسلاميه لا فرق
بينها وبين الشعب التركي
فالتميز او التفريق قد يقع
باساليب او بالانظمه التي تحكم تلك البلاد
فلذلك نحن لا نرى البلدان العربيه ام
الدول الاسلاميه دولا بعيده عن تركيا انما
الامه الاسلاميه هي امه واحده وكذلك
الاوطان العربيه والاسلاميه نحن لا نراها
بعيده فنرى دمشقى
مدينتنا وايضا نعتبر اسطنبول مدينه سوريين
وكذلك
نعتبر بغداد مدينتنا وايضا نعتبر انقره
مدينه العراقيين
يعني يمكن ان
نكسر او نزيد الامثله فلذلك الهدف الاساسي
في الرؤيه السياسيه للرئيس اردوغان تحصين
العلاقات والتعزيزها والتضامن والتعانق
والتعاون مع الجيران في المرتبه الاولى مع
الدول الاسلاميه والعربيه كلها منذ 21
عاما عفوا البعض يطرح السؤال يعني ما
الضامن عدم حدوث تقلبات حاده جديده في
العلاقات التركيه العربيه كما رايناه في
فترات سابقه نتساءل عن ربما دوافع
ومحركات هذه السياسه الخارجيه التركيه
تجاه مختلف الدول العربيه هل هي مبادئ
محدده هل هي رؤيه الرئيس في حد ذاته والتي
تتجاوز في كثير من الاحيان ربما رؤيه
المسؤولين ام الدوافع الاقتصاديه المجرده
هناك دوافع كثيره لكن اذا سالت عن الضامن
الضامن هو الشعوب
فالنظم قد تختلف بين حينما اخر لكن الضامن
الاساسي هو وحده الامه الاسلاميه فنرى
الان بالامس راينا احتفالات في شبارها
عواصم العالم العربي والاسلامي فهذا هو
الضامن الاساسي لكن النظم التي تختلف
اساليبها بين حين واخر نرى يعني هناك
تضامنا قويا وتحسين العلاقات في القمه
وياتي زمان العلاقات تتوتر هذا التوتر لا
ينبثق من الموقف التركي لان الموقف التركي
او الاردوغاني او السياسه الخارجيه لحزب
العداله والتنميه تعتمد على الاراده
الشعبيه على سبيل المثال عندما توترت
العلاقات مع مصر الشقيقه كان السبب هو
يعني
قتل الابرياء في الشباب امام كاميرات
بالنسبه للانقلاب العسكري تركي نعم اتخذ
موقفا الى جوار الاراده الشعبيه لكن بعد
مضيه زمن
فبادرت تركيا الى التطعيمه مصر نفس الشيء
مع سوريا ومع الدول الاخرى يعني المبادئ
الاساسيه في السياسه الخارجيه التركيه نعم
تعتمد على الاراده الشعبيه على احترام
حقوق الناس لكن بطبيعه الحال هناك عوامل
اقتصاديه هناك عوامل ثقافيه هناك عوامل
سياحيه هناك عوامل سياسيه هناك عوامل
عسكريه عوامل كثيره بس
ؤال اخر هناك هواجس عربيه ايضا من التدخل
التركي مثلا في سوريا في ليبيا العمليات
العسكريه في شمال العراق وقلق حتى مما
يسميه البعض السعي التركي لاحياء
التعبير الهيمنه العثمانيه على العالم
العربي كيف ستعالج تركيا وبماذا يمكن الرد
على هذه الهواجس والتخوفات التي يبديها
البعض هذا
تضليل بارز لماذا لان التدخل التركي الذي
يسمونها التدخل في سوريا لم تتدخل تركيا
للحدود السوريه او الجيش السوري ام النظام
السوري انما كانت المناطق التي دخلت تركيا
فيها او يعني
اطلقت عمليه عسكريه كانت في اطار مكافحه
الارهاب على سبيل المثال في عمليات درع
الفرات كان ضد الارهابيين وعمليات غصن
الزيتون كانت ضد الارهابيين عمليه نبع
نبع السلام كذلك كلها كان ضد التنظيمات
الارهابيه فهذه التدخلات او العمليات
العسكريه في الحقيقه تضمن وحده الاراضي
السوريه لان تركيا تقول لسنا نطمع في شبر
من اراضي جيراننا انما للحفاظ على امننا
القومي نكافح الارهابيين عندما يستتب
الامن هناك وعندما يستطيع النظام السوري
السيطره السياده الكامله تركيا
ستنسحب من هناك فان هناك سته ملايين سوري
على حدود تركيا والنظام السوري لا يهتم به
فان لم يقم تقم تركيا بتلك العمليات
العسكريه لطرد الارهابيين فلايقاف النزوح
فسياتي سته ملايين لاجئ ايضا
[تصفيق]
العرب فيه كثير من التعليقات على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي للاسف صبغات تشاؤم من
ان العرب مفعول بهم وليس لهم اي دور لكن
ان اتحاد العرب مع تركيا تركيا التي لديها
تكنولوجيا التي تلعب دورا اقليميا بارزا
وحتى عالميا على الساحه الدوليه التحالف
كهذا هل يمكن ان يحدث الفرق باعتقادك من
دون ان الشبكه الجواب مباشره على سؤالك
لكن دعيني بعجاله ايضا اشير الى ان موضوع
الهويه والانتماء حاضر بشكل اساسي في
السياسه الخارجيه الجديده
وطبعا تفعيل العلاقات الثقافيه
والاقتصاديه مع الدول العربيه يهدف في جزء
منه الى التقليل من اي تداعيات سلبيه على
العلاقات السياسيه قد تظهر مستقبلا لذلك
هي رؤيا متكامله من دون ان شك طبعا هناك
قدرات كبيره لدى الطرفين في العالم العربي
في تركيا التكامل الاقتصادي ياتي في
المرتبه الاولى ليدعم موضوع الثبات
الخارجيه وانما ضمان امنها المستقبله ايضا
في منطقه في واحده من اكثر مناطق العالم
عدم استقرار وايضا في مرحله مهمه جدا تشهد
تراجعا في النفوذ الامريكي وصعودا لنفوذ
دول اخرى قد يؤدي الى تهديد
ربما في هذه اللعبه الكبيره لكن اود ان
اقف معك عند نقطه مهمه اشار اليها احد
الضيوف في فيلم الليله تحدث عن العلاقات
الاقتصاديه ونحن هنا نتحدث عن جانب
الاقتصادي نعم الجانب الامني العسكري مع
تركيا بين العرب وتركيا قال بان الجانب
الغربي لا يتاثر هذا البعد الاقتصادي
والمصالح الاقتصاديه والصفقات الاقتصاديه
ان حدثت هزات سياسيه او خلافات سياسيه
بعكس العرب الذين تؤثر بشكل واضح وجلي اي
خلافات سياسيه عابره يعني تغلق الحدود
وتقطع المصالح الاقتصاديه وغير ذلك ما
الذي يمكن ان يجنب ه تحالف مستقبلي ان كان
هذه
الزعزعات والتفكير بطريقه ربما استراتيجيه
تحمل مصالح على المدى البعيد هذا ما يحاول
الجانب التركي ان يعني يقوله للجانب
العربي في حقيقه لكن ماذا عن العرب يعني
كيف يمكن ان يحل هذه المعضله لان المشكله
تاتي من من هذا الاتجاه الى ذلك هي علاقه
تبادليه وعلى الطرفان ان يكون على تفاهم
فيما يخدمان عليه الجانب العربي عليه ان
يفكر بطريقه اكثر نضج اعتقد ان حاله عدم
الاستقرار ورده الفعل هذه التي يعني تنتقل
من السياسه الى الاقتصاد مردها امران
اساسيا الاول ان معظم هذه الدول العربيه
هي دول ريعيه وليست دول الصناعيه وبالتالي
تعتقد انه من السهل عليها قطع العلاقات
الاقتصاديه وان تكون الامور على ما يرام
بالنسبه لها اقتصاديا لكن هذا الامر طبعا
يؤدي الى نتائج سلبيه على المدى البعيد
على هذه الدول الاقتصاديا وعلى العلاقاتها
السياسيه لانه اذا ما كانت العلاقات
الاقتصاديه موصوله حتى في اوقات التوتر
يسهل هذا
عوده العلاقات السياسيه بشكل سريع الى
حالتها الطبيعيه لكن اذا كانت منقطعه
تماما هذا يصعب العمل وهذا ما جرح حقيقه
خلال السنوات القليله الماضيه حتى يعني
موضوع التبادل التجاري مع الدول العربيه
ضعيف جدا بما في ذلك دول المثال كما راينا
في التقرير يعني الدوله مثل المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ربما الاقتصاد الاول في
العالم العربي حجم التبادل التجاري مع
تركيا 4.5 مليار دولار هذا حجم متواضع جدا
يعني حجم التجاره التركيه مع دوله مثل مصر
مع ما من يعني حمولات اشكاليه في هذه
العلاقه كانت اكثر من 5 مليار دولار حتى
في خضم الازمه بين الطرفين هذا يعني ان
هناك مساحه
لزياده التعاون الاقتصادي والاستثماري بين
هذه الدول بشكل كبير هناك على سبيل المثال
الدول العربيه حوالي 10 او 11 الدول
العربيه تستثمر اكثر من 250 مليار دولار
في السندات الامريكيه لماذا لا يكون هناك
مثلا تفكير تجاه الجان تركي خاصه ان
الجانب التركي اثبت خلال سنوات القليله
الماضيه انه لاعب او شريك جاد وذو مصداقيه
ويلبي الالتزامات التي تكون عليه عندما
يكون هناك حاجه بخلاف الدول الغربيه التي
قد تنسحب في وقت ما تعتقد انت انها ملتزمه
بامنك وبضمان استقرارك ثم تجد نفسك منعزلا
ومحيدا في مواجهه المخاطر اعود مره اخرى
الى ضيفنا الكريم في اسطنبول السيد الرسول
سيد الرسول اعود بك مره اخرى ربما الى
نقطه البدايه من الواضح ان كلا الطرفين
لديهم مصالح مشتركه لديهم رغبه هناك نوع
من النضج الان بات اكبر لدى العالم العربي
في شكل هذه العلاقه مع تركيا لكن نعود الى
نقطه البدايه وهي الانتخابات الحاليه
ونتائجها يعني لاول مره رئيس اردوغان اضطر
لخوض جوله انتخابات ثانيه مقاعد حزب
العداله والتنميه تراجعت في البرلمان
خاسره ثمانيه وعشرين مقعدا رغم ان التحالف
طبعا هو الفائز بالاغلبيه
نتساءل عن انعكاسات ربما هذا التراجع على
السياسه خاصه مما سمعناه من اصوات ابدت
مواقف معاديه سواء في
الشارع او حتى لدى ساسه تجاه العلاقات مع
العالم العربي اجمالا
اذا قارنا الاصوات التي حصل عليها حزب
العداله والتنميه في
الانتخابات الماضيه كانت هناك نسبه
42% وفي الانتخابات الاخيره التي اجريت
قبل اسبوعين 14 مايو حصل حزب العداله
بالتنميه
35% هناك تراجع في اصوات حزب العداله
بالتنميه البعض يظن ان الناخب التركي يعني
قد دار ظهره لحزب العداله والتنميه الامر
بالعكس
فحزب العداله والتنميه او لا اريد ان ادخل
في لعبه الارقام ومن ومن حصل على اكثر وان
ادار الناخب يعني ظهره ام لا لكن نتساءل
عن شريحه هامه في الشارع التركي ابدت وجهه
نظرها في هذا الموضوع وسؤال كيف يمكن ان
تؤثر على سياسات تركيا تجاه العرب في هذا
الموضوع
نعم نعم ساجيب عن هذا ايضا تمهيدا اقول
هذه الكلمات
فحسب العداله بالتنميه اقام تحالفا مع حزق
الحركه القوميه مع حزب الرفاهي الجديد مع
حزب لوحه الكبرى
فالاصوات التي تراجعت او راحت من حزب
العداله والتنميه لم تذهب الى المعارضه
انما ذهبت الى اما حزب الحركه القوميه اما
حزب
رفاه الجديد او الوحده الكبرى فلذلك وان
كان هناك ظاهر في تراجع في اصوات حزب
التنميه الا ان التحالف ككل هو الفائز في
البرلمان وكذلك في في جوله الاعاده
الرئاسه فلذلك هناك معارضه نعم تستغل هذه
الارقام فتقول حزب العداله والتنميه تراجع
لا حزب العداله والتنميه الان هو عضو في
العضو الكبير في التحالف تحالف الجمهور
فالاصوات التي كانت في حوزه
حزب الاعداد التنميه ايضا بقيت في حفظه
اردوغان لكن في حزب الحركه القوميه او حزب
الرفاه الجديد حزب الرفاه الجديد هو يعتبر
حزبنا ايضا حزب الاستاذ اربكان ابنه
اربكان فلذلك المعارضه نعم تقوم بدعايه ان
حزب العداله ترى لا المعادله السياسيه لم
تتغير والقوه السياسيه سياسيه
لكن لكن رغم ذلك اعذرني يعني كانت هناك
مواقف وتصريحات سمعناها في الشارع التركي
تظهر اعداء مثلا
للاجئين السوريين تطلعا الى طردهم رفضا
لمن يتحدث باللغه العربيه نتساءل حقيقه
كمشاهدين عرب يعني ما نسبه هذا الصوت ان
صح التعبير في الشارع التركي
نسبه هذا الصوت قرابه
واحد ونصف او اثنين بالمئه فهذا حزب النصر
الذي اسسه
وهو يعني بنى حزبه على كراهيه الاجانب
وعلى راسها الاخوه العرب فيكرهون العرب
لكن هؤلاء كما قلت اثنين بالمئه اما
اغلبيه الاتراك فكذلك
التحالف الحاكم في تركيا هو الذي
يحمي هو الذي لا يريد الترحيل لاي سوري
الا بشكل طواعي في اطار امني قانوني ولذلك
هذا
الحزب حزب النصر الذي يتبنى الكراهيه
كراهيه العرب هو تحالف معه حزب الشعب
الجمهوري مع سيد كمال كردستانو وهم خسروا
باجماعهم والان
خلافهم فيما بينهم شديد فلذلك الاخوه
السوريون العرب
فليطمئنوا ان تركيا ان تركيا
تستضيفهم ولن يسبب لم تسمع بشكل جليل واضح
من اصوات عديده من داخل تركيا سيد الرسول
سؤال اخي الدكتور علي واود ان اختم دافع
وجاله الشكل التقارب العربي التركي
باعتقادك في المرحله المقبله وما الذي
يوفره من فرص ومصالح للطرفين انا اعتقد
الان ان هناك برلمان يسيطر عليه حزب
العداله والتنميه سيكون هناك توجه اكبر
لتعزيز علاقات تركيا الاقتصاديه
والاستثماريه والثقافيه مع محيطها
الاقليمي من بين ذلك طبعا المنطقه العربيه
وايضا مع اسيا الوسطى والعالم التركي
واذربيجان بالاضافه طبعا الى علاقات تركيا
التقليديه مع اوروبا والولايات المتحده
وروسيا اعتقد ان هناك الان مرحله من كما
ذكرت من حاله عدم التصعيد يجب على الطرفين
ان يستغلها لكي بطبيعه الحال لكي يوثقاع
خاتمه بشكل كبير
في مركز ابن خلدون بجامعه قطر كما اشكر
جزيل الشكر السيد الرسول توصون النائب
السابق في حزب العداله والتنميه كان معنا
من اسطنبول ختام حلقتنا هذه من برنامج
القصه بقي نعود نلقاكم باذن الله مع بقيه
بقصه جديده الاسبوع القادم السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]